hey 42 here I'm sorry to be the one to
break this to you but the reality you
think you live in is in fact a complete
and not a lie when you walk around out
there in the world each day the ground
Beneath Your Feet probably feels
reassuringly solid but I'm afraid it's
just an illusion a comforting falsehood
you see the center of our planet holds a
secret and if you had the time and
resources to dig down deep below the
Earth's crust sooner or later you'd find
it a colossal Cavern lit by a miniature
Sun that's full of wonders beyond your
wildest dreams
okay don't worry this isn't my way of
announcing that I've decided to take
this channel in a radical new Direction
what I've just described aren't my own
views but those of a surprising number
of people around the world people who
are of the opinion that the surface of
our planet is nothing more than a shell
and that's inside this hollow casing all
matter of amazing things lie and wait
for us
exactly what those amazing things might
be depends on who you ask many Hollow
Earth theorists claim there's a garden
of eden-like Tropical Paradise down
there and most agree that this strange
hidden world is populated though by who
or what is a topic of some debate
some believe that technologically
advanced race have made their home there
in a city called Agatha other
suggestions include Giants Nazis and the
then lost tribes of Israel some people
have even gone as far as to claim that's
the recent rash of UFO sightings
reported across the globe may actually
have come not from outer space but from
Inner Space
if all of this is giving you strong
flatter Vibes you're pretty much on the
right lines but there's a surprising
difference between those two outlandish
Fringe beliefs to try and put this
diplomatically you won't find too many
people with an astrophysics degree who
believe the Earth is flat the idea that
Earth is hollow on the other hand has
been ardently believed by some of the
greatest scientists in recent history
modern Flat Earth beliefs mostly stem
back to the work of an English writer
called Samuel robofen who believed he'd
scientifically proven the flatness of
our planet with his famous Bedford level
experiment I did a whole video on that
recently so I won't go into detail here
except to say that when it comes to the
sharpness of tools in sheds so to speak
robofen was a [ __ ] sledgehammer as
well as believing girth was flat he also
thought he'd invented a miracle drug
capable of curing any disease this
apparent Panacea led to the deaths of
several people Brave or possibly foolish
enough to ingest it including robuffin's
own son in a way you could argue this
cure kind of worked corpses are
impervious to disease after all but the
fact their loved one no longer had that
nasty case of herpes probably wasn't
much of a consolation to the devastated
relatives of the deceased modern Hollow
Earth beliefs are usually attributed to
an American chap called John cleeve Sims
Jr he was born in the late 18th century
Sims made it his live submission to
spread his hollow Earth message far and
wide and by the 1820s he'd become so
influential that he very nearly
convinced the U.S government to fund an
expedition to find the giant entrances
to the underworld he believed were
located at the poles
but Sims was by no means the first
person to claim the Earth was Hollow in
fact almost every civilization in
history has had at least some kind of
concept of a hidden world beneath our
feet from the Aztecs to the Inuits not
to mention the fact that something
similar crops up in almost every major
religion hell in Christianity Shoal in
Judaism patala in Hinduism johannam in
Islam and naraka in Buddhism to name
just a few what I'm trying to say is we
humans have actually been kind of
obsessed with all things Hollow Earth
for a very long time but about 350 years
ago something strange happened hollow
Earth theory stepped out of the realm of
myth and religion and found itself
uncomfortably close to The Cutting Edge
of science
you see what we think of as a modern
hollow Earth theory wasn't dreamed up by
a child poisoning tool like Samuel
robuffer long before Sims arrived on the
scene the foundations for a hollow Earth
have been laid by some of the most
brilliant individuals in the history of
our species
probably the first person to investigate
the possibility from a purely scientific
perspective was German polymath a
fanzius kircher if kircher's name sounds
familiar you might have come across him
in my video on the world's most
mysterious book the Voynich manuscript
admittedly he didn't cover himself in
glory in not one but Kutcher is
considered to have been one of the
greatest thinkers of his age there's a
reason he's often referred to as a
master of a hundred Arts well 99
just watch the voinette's video after
having spent some time exploring the
creative Mount Vesuvius in 1638 kircher
came up with a theory that all mountains
rivers and oceans of the earth were
connected below ground by a giant
network of navigable Caverns filled with
fire and water kirch's ideas may not
really resemble modern Hollow Earth
beliefs but less than 30 years later
another legendary scientist Edmund
Halley introduced a theory that's much
more familiar to us Holly was kind of a
big deal he was Britain's second ever
Royal astronomer a fellow of the Royal
Society and he was good mates with some
random Daydreamer by the name of Sir
Isaac Newton he's best known today for
being the first person to realize that
comets orbit the Sun in a predictable
way just like the Earth does but that's
just one of a great number of
contributions he made to science during
his lifetime in simple terms Ed
was a genius a genius who firmly
believed the Earth was Hollow according
to Halley's Hollow Earth model our
planet's crossed is actually a shell of
rock about 500 Miles thick and inside it
are two smaller shells surrounding a
solid core kind of like solar system
scale Russian dolls he believed these
shells were surrounded by a breathable
atmosphere and were therefore most
likely inhabited he also thought that
the northern lights were caused by gas
escaping from inside the earth and
interacting with Earth's magnetic field
several other important scientific
thinkers made their own additions to the
hollow Earth Concept in the centuries
after Halley's death including Scottish
physicists Sir John Leslie and first
president of Boston University William
Fairfield Warren amongst others as the
theory gained traction it began cropping
up in popular fiction too Jules Vern's
Journey to the Center of the Earth is
the most famous example but there are
literally thousands of stories based on
the hollow Earth theme even legendary
Italian womanizer Casanova got involved
though that man had a one-track mind so
instead of aliens or superhumans he
populated Earth's core with a bunch of
Randy hermaphroditic Dwarfs if you're
interested in reading that one by the
way it's called Iko samiron thought I'd
save you the trouble of trying to find
it by Googling Randy hermaphroditic
dwarves not a good idea but what does
all of this mean for hollow Earth theory
clearly it's been an important part of
culture and religion across the world
throughout human history and some of the
greatest Geniuses in recent memory have
been vocal believers
is it about time we started taking
Hollow earthas a bit more seriously
yeah no definitely not
the likes of kircher and Halle were
indisputably brilliant men but they were
also people of their time and much of
the signs we take for granted today
simply didn't exist in the 17th century
the collective knowledge of the human
race is a bit like a giant wall every
generation builds on the work of all
those who came before and the scientists
mathematicians and philosophers who are
dedicated enough to bring original ideas
into the world each get to lay a little
knowledge brick of their own on top of
the rest the men and women who are
pushing the boundaries today likely
aren't any more intelligent than
previous generations they simply have
the benefit of beginning their Journeys
much higher up the wall
Pali believed the Earth was Hollow
because it solved a problem he'd come
across in another area of Interest
magnetism at the end of the 17th century
he set off on a year-long voyage of the
Atlantic Ocean to study and map the
Earth's magnetic field the voyage was a
huge success but Holly had expected
Earth's magnetic field to be constant
and unmoving
a year of taking thousands of compass
readings all over the Atlantic showed
him that wasn't the case hollow Earth
theory was his attempt to make sense of
experimental results he didn't
understand in other words it was a
hypothesis if Earth's magnetic field was
fluctuating Hallie reasoned that
something must be interfering with it
competing magnetic fields from large
objects inside the Earth
perhaps of course his hypothesis was
completely wrong but he arrived at it
through experimental observation and
logical reasoning in other words he was
just a scientist doing science
the fact is pretty much every brilliant
scientist that's ever lived has believed
some weird and wonderful things that
would sound ridiculous today Charles
Darwin had no idea how genetic
inheritance actually worked despite it
being a fundamental part of his theory
of evolution and physicists Lord Kelvin
was convinced he calculated the exact
age of the Earth when in actual fact he
was off by about 4.4 billion years no
doubt the leading scientists of the
current generation will be shown to have
made a few major blunders of their own
in the not too distant future and hollow
Earth theory was undeniably a blunder
these days there's plenty of evidence
that proves Beyond doubt that our planet
isn't Hollow the fact that we all stick
to it through gravity for one thing a
hollow Earth like the one Sims envisaged
would have less than one percent of the
mass of a solid its sphere meaning
gravity at the surface would be a
fraction of what we actually experience
not to mention the fact that a
planet-sized shell of rock 500 Miles
thick would simply collapse on the video
wait
the scientists have determined the
composition of the planet by measuring
things like Earth's gravity magnetic
field and the progress of seismic waves
as they travel through the ground deep
beneath our feet that's how we know the
planet is made up of three main layers
the crust the mantle and the core none
of which would make a comfortable home
for a giant or a Nazi there really is no
room for ambiguity here but there is one
small problem with all of these pieces
of evidence they're all a little bit
esoteric making them fairly easy to
dismiss by anyone uninterested in taking
the time to understand them ultimately
the only Surefire way to make a hollow
Earth or believe the center of our
planet is solid would be to dig a giant
hole and setting them down there of
course they wouldn't get all that far
before the intense heat would literally
boil them alive
but hey sometimes the truth hurts thanks
for watching